hello and welcome to the city of lingual
lastima most are from Turkey Kevon cuts
Nadal rule so what is he doing no Kings
Indian okay Kings Indian it's fairly
popular among among Turkish players as
wire and if thought it would happen my
taking is almost mandatory what is that
on d4 I mean taking his almost mandatory
okay do you go out for here or 23 is
also fairly good
just centralized so wow that's already a
terrible position would like em Quincy
three maybe 23 for f-4s strongest we
should be five is a great ending Wow
okay so if I go F for now okay I threads
now to open up the long lag and also e6
what is his reply we should be three
maybe or some some thumbs and stuff yeah
it also doesn't save them what is what
is your safe and I don't see it
tween a chain made
black resins and it that has a very
shady reputation not taking I'm not sure
how bad it is it has a really bad
reputation but I added on the game once
and it wasn't all that clear so g6 maybe
instead yeah this is already completely
I mean took them 20 seconds to get to
the Los position hy it's all good now
yeah already the fantastic position
[Music]
Quincy three already here was strong and
now qf force is deadly just a deadly
position okay and over it's made could
have taken actually right okay it's
enough it's just going to be made so I
can desperado this but I'm still
threatening the server long diagonal is
just going to kill them yeah okay guys
thanks for watching